(bright music)
- Driverless taxi company
Cruise has had a bumpy month.
Its autonomous driving permits
were suspended in California
after a woman was dragged 20
feet under one of its vehicles.
The company then paused
operations in every single one
of its US markets to focus
on rebuilding public trust.
And that could be a challenge.
See, as driverless companies try
to increase public
acceptance of their tech,
they're rolling out more
and more vehicles onto public roads.
But that increases the probability
that one of these cars
could have an accident
that damages the paint work
and the reputation of the technology.
While every safe journey
may be one step forward,
every collision can be two steps back.
A recent AAA study found that
the number of Americans afraid
of self-driving technology
has actually increased.
So how can driverless car
companies rebuild trust
after a crash?
Okay, so in case you missed it,
here's how Cruise lost
its permits in California,
On October 2nd at around
9:30 PM on the corner
of 5th and Market Street in San Francisco,
a pedestrian was hit by a
car, not the Cruise one,
and fell into the path of a
driverless Cruise vehicle.
The Cruise vehicle braked hard and stopped
and then attempted to pull
over to the side of the road.
The problem was that the pedestrian
who was struck was actually
still under the Cruise vehicle,
and according to the DMV,
was pulled 20 feet forwards
of speeds of up to seven miles an hour.
The DMV said this may have caused
further injury to the pedestrian.
Now, Cruise said it spoke to
the DMV about the incident,
but the DMV said Cruise didn't mention
that the vehicle had
attempted to pull over.
Cruise, however, said it showed the DMV,
a full video of the incident.
California's DMV then suspended
Cruise's driverless license
to carry paying passengers and crucially,
it's license to test on public roads,
saying the manufacturer's vehicles
are not safe for the public's operation.
So if Cruise isn't allowed
to be conducting driverless operations
on roads in California,
how can it rebuild trust?
- It's particularly important
that the company does figure out a way
just because California
is its biggest market.
- That's WSJ's autos reporter Ryan Felton.
- You're not gonna ever feel
that it's safe until you
actually experience it.
It's hard to imagine what
other sort of scenarios exist
to rebuild that trust other
than just seeing through
that people experience it.
- With its licenses revoked in California,
Cruise may have to turn
to the other states
it was operating in to get
back out there and demonstrate
that its technology can
be safe in the real world.
But there is still a path for the company
to resume driverless
operations in California.
- The DMV has sort of spelled
out to the company it says,
steps it can take to get back on the road,
get its permit.
We don't know what those
steps are at this point.
- But the fact that the DMV
is regulating this industry
and revoking real licenses
from real robotaxis
in the real world when they
have real safety issues
is a sign that driverless technology
is in some way finally real.
- Like, it's happening
and barring some sort of
full scale pullback across the US,
which seems highly
unlikely this is happening.
There's mechanisms in place to take action
when something does happen,
then I think that's what you're seeing.
- Now, Cruise isn't the
only driverless car company
operating in the US.
And while it has been
experiencing setbacks,
others have been making headway.
Alphabet's Waymo, for example,
recently expanded its
operations across San Francisco
and announced that it was offering rides
through Uber's platform in Phoenix.
But setbacks for one
company can have impacts
on the reputation of the
technology as a whole.
And what's not clear is
how much further driverless
technology will have to go
to convince the majority of
the public that it's safe
or how many accidents
will happen along the way.
A ladies mayor recently
wrote to the president
of California's Public
Utilities Commission
to voice serious concerns about a decision
to approve an autonomous
vehicle program in the city.
And there are still those who believe
that Cruise has rolled out its technology
on public roads too quickly.
Cruise, for its part, has since announced
that they're taking a number of steps
to improve how the company operates
including issuing a
voluntary software recall.
- The vast majority of things
are a hundred percent foolproof.
That is just the reality here
that we're at a point now
where there are companies actually
using this technology
actually commercializing it.
There's going to be incidents
that happen just like, if a driver,
a human driver gets into a crash
that there could be ramifications as well.
- So while Cruise might not
be operating autonomously
on Californian roads in the near future,
the October 2nd incident is
unlikely to be the last incident
that an autonomous vehicle
experiences on its road
to building public trust.
(gentle music)